[Music]
in poor doggy news years whole submitted
by I know kung-fu I don't know kung-fu
you know I'm not a little bit a dog seer
completely fell off after an allergic
reaction to hair dye Wow come on isn't
it illegal to dye your dog or animal I
think it's no but people do it though
like it fell off in one piece
they have doggy okay if they have doggy
stuff but I think like painting like
turtle shells and like dying maybe like
stuff like that is not for animals yeah
that's cruelty my paris hilton's dogs
are always pink or something it's not
illegal cuz they have doggy nail polish
and then dog he stole it has to be
non-toxic like me for him but that's
probably only made within the last like
two years it was tested on animals until
they discovered which one like wasn't
didn't didn't eat the make your ears
fall off I mean they used to put toxic
thing on like their face like makeup and
everything yeah Mac is like a big one of
that I don't find that wait Mac Mac
takes on tests on animals yeah a lot of
makeup companies why don't they just on
humans are the people that don't earn
the companies that don't test on animals
what do they do
I don't know how they doing it like back
back back back in a day like the [ __ ]
Napoleon times then they do like [ __ ]
let ass paint like crazy ass [ __ ] let
paints make them look white right let
paint look at this degree you just
straight up toxic chemicals for like
makeup and all that [ __ ] they just need
to drink water why don't we all just go
to our natural form I'm done with that
me too you want furry women yeah sure I
don't mind not me all right in Thailand
I like smooth [ __ ] I like smooth [ __ ]
too I like smooth [ __ ] too but if
everyone but if no one ever showed me
the smooth [ __ ] you want it now yeah
it's cuz we know the better life that's
true because when I if you ever have a
hairy [ __ ] I would I wouldn't be like
Percy that's nasty I [ __ ] the [ __ ] out
of it still
okay I just prefer I just pictured like
a vagina with a lot of hair but then
it's all like squishy from all the
juices and it's hairy
yeah man he said I'll [ __ ] the [ __ ] out
of it and I just got this disgusting
kind right now and I was in my mind and
because he's talking I pictured you with
that blond hair down there I don't even
have here anymore I lasered it well
that's not what I pictured
and I've seen you naked rosy picture
something else huh even though you've
seen her naked
yeah because [ __ ] at least it matched
no I saw I saw the vintage porn ones I
think this from like the 80s or
seventies and that's exactly the image I
pop right back in my head it was so
gross it goes all the way up to their
belly but it's almost like a bikini or
better it gets frothy yeah it's all
[ __ ] curly hey looking like a poodles
longer I mean this one said but I feel
like it might be a little bit better
than what we're talking about anyway so
this dog owner in Thailand
she has come under fire for dyeing her
dog's hair or so it's the ears and the
tail that this dog is Pomeranian named
iffy just leave him alone
q he got an allergic reaction oh [ __ ]
so at first she posted to Facebook
saying like hey the person dyeing the
hair cuz she took it to a dog grooming
place so it was like dog saver we're
supposed to be right yeah and so they're
saying that they dyed it and the rat
didn't spoil for 40 minutes oh my like
that's [ __ ] what they do the human
hair I don't know I thought my hair dyed
now is sitting there from yeah well felt
like three days
it is like 3040 minutes yeah I felt like
I was in there forever
I don't know for a dog how did the doggy
was sitting in for like that small
amount of area cuz I could see it like a
whole head cuz it took me eight hours to
do this but it was like blonde and then
the blue and then it was a lot but I
don't know if it's just 40 minutes
seemed like a lot to me if I'm not her
dog and then the hair is just this long
like it shouldn't take that much - boy
yeah that's right yeah that's why it
seemed excessive to me so then she
posted on Twitter both deer
I like how you like that you question
how did the dog sit there for so long so
if that means in your head it was
sitting in a [ __ ] chair reading
People magazine where in my head I just
saw the foil and the dog just running
around but you're like how did he sit
there for that and nobody picked up on
it yes it was a tail right and then so
she posted on Facebook saying like hey
my dog's ears used to stand up but ever
since I dyed it red
they drew didn't fall off hold on
they're about to dude she said they're
about to fall off I want to see the fall
off pictures see my like you know they
don't look cute and that's not I'm
probably unhealthy it's we're gonna get
infected dog with no ear I always pull
like my dog's ears back and they look
cuter like that like a seal Chinese eyes
on my dogs I don't like the stick your
ear dog erupting I like it for student
reads I don't like it I don't like it I
like it but they look more aggressive
hey I don't like that you don't like the
way it lets me know what the pop I don't
like the process I don't like the
talking donkey
yeah I don't like the process is that
the tail yeah yeah yeah yeah they do it
for a bully breeds like it would have
done to my dog yeah I don't like that
some of them is for health reasons yeah
but some of them just for aesthetics
it's so motorist cocker spaniels is for
health reasons yeah yeah my cooker yeah
but like dogs like Dobermans I didn't
they like dopest hell when they do do I
don't like it but I feel bad for it so
I've seen them do it it's horrible
yeah [ __ ] that I've seen them do like
backyard ones that's [ __ ] it's okay
it's not really a popsicle sticking like
some duct tape
impressin did I cut it and I cut your
earring whoa that sucks yeah suck it
doesn't do nothing yeah no it doesn't it
doesn't but back in the day it had a
purpose and they do it for sure though
the purpose they would have hunting dogs
those hunting traditions yeah yeah yeah
they had a much hunting dogs and then
when they're fighting with whatever
animal that they're hunting sometimes
their tails would get bit off or their
ears would get bit off so they did it to
protect the dog yeah
which is great but we don't do that
anymore they just do it to look tough
the Dobermans look sick but I agree yeah
let me just smash your head they do it
to babies to like smash your head to
make their head fit a different shape
yeah
try making a triangle yeah they do a
skull elongating yeah to my face you
look like a conehead you come out that
way though look at you long gated skulls
like Egyptian yeah but they come out
that way no no but then they move it
they keep yeah the keeping is you know
how they do it they wrap the head yeah
with some yeah the neck to give you
different rings and then I gauge your
neck until your I kind of think it looks
dope I just want to see what it looks
like with hair I imagine it bald like a
head if you if you get to choose any of
this I'm for it if you get to say I
would like you to be that's my point or
if you can't as a dog I chose to stretch
his neck out I'm off like like your neck
is always like going like backwards like
it's heavy or you're really [ __ ] fast
that right we all have heads like that
like it's like a big [ __ ] I can
imagine it
that's what Tyco the head I do already
know but it's you got a look at
elongated your head I know I know what
you're saying
it's like this video yeah some are tall
[ __ ] and then in the neck but I want to
see the dog's ear so hours later oh wait
first of all she asked the grooming
salon staff about the ears drooping and
then they said that it was normal and
that the ears would be back to normal at
least she didn't ask from ask for them
to die that dog's dick I'm as if the oh
well the dog still only do have very
dicks it's the way he looks he looks
kind of like a match if the whole hog
was white in there like red tips and I
was like oh what if he made the dick a
little match too that'd be pretty cute
and I was like wait that's my stuff
cause it's ears fell off so isn't the
dick already like a red lipstick only I
want to say right it's always erect
there's literally a bone in there Wow
yeah there's always a bone in there you
didn't know that what go play with the
dog enough no I didn't play with my
dog's dick whose bone no there's a bone
inside yes
it's called a bone yeah we don't got no
bone we don't have a bone but they do
have a bone inside it your IQ drop like
[ __ ] 20 points right now about dog
dicks it's not always erect a dog is
always correct there's a bone in it it's
ready lipstick yeah and that's what it's
ready because it's always ready oh you
can't be kind already it always ready
and have a bone and not always a
lipstick a baculum see it's not a bone
that's a back you'll get it it's in the
dog's penis yeah yeah that's where the
term button you get to know your dog
better not like that I'm glad we have
female dogs I know it's a boat it's in
the but I'll come out but it's always
isn't it getting erect when it comes out
no it's already a vet right inside it's
just when it comes out when it wants so
how does it come out I mean that's it
could be it's just like an elevator like
it just comes out whatever it's absent
in human penis but as presents and other
primates primates such as gorilla and
chimpanzee [ __ ] I need the other one oh
[ __ ] that's good
located above the male urethra and it
aids in sexual reproduction and
sufficient stiffness during sexual
penetration the baculum and female
mammals is known as the bail bonds in
the clitoris anyway back to this poor
doofy here where the girl's got a bone -
yeah little bow a woman never dull women
she's thought about [ __ ]
[Applause]
other than humans so much - no I need to
watch more Animal Planet anyway so diff
these ears started being really itchy
started showing signs of an allergic
reaction so and because it was like
flaking and everything oh that sucks
and then that's come out so this is a
photo I showed you previously oh my god
oh poor baby it's not bits of it I mean
it just looks wild
damn that's earring it's a hand it looks
like a furry cookie wait do we have an
after picture of the dog without the
ears wasn't a diaper on all that whole
chunk oh that's crazy it looks like it
like like like burned off acid like it's
not bleeding her skull it turned black
and his
imagine that Kong yeah yeah that's crazy
tension anything about the other year it
was just the left ear and or the tail so
I don't know about the other ear or the
tail I wonder if he already had like a
like a cut or something and then like an
open wound just went through it but both
ears drew I don't know that's weak I
just try to keep the dog names yeah yeah
so she the dog owner says like I blame
myself it's my fault you should live
with that ears you should live with what
wait a minute we had to say that to her
like if they tell her like if it's been
something that people have been doing
and then she takes them to a dog
grooming where they like back it up yeah
then it's kind of hard to be like good
because I'm sure some humans had a bad
reaction to hair dye yeah like all girls
like some girls their hair just falls
out I mean that's not I mean the whose
fault really is it like it just happens
yeah I said I knew we did Jake a muse on
a woman who like her whole head swell
ever she look like an alien you guys
don't remember no I need to go find that
one sorry like Megamind like you see the
veins in her head and [ __ ]
[Music]